[Music]
[Applause]
he's Matt Hasselbeck former NFL
quarterback led the Seahawks to uh the
Super Bowl and former ESPN NFL analyst
what do you make of these uh like that
coaching decision to leave BC to be a
defensive coordinator with the
Packers yeah hey how are you I'm glad I
get to be the mercedesbenz guest by the
way that's a pretty that's a good
feeling right uh no listen it was
shocking like as a Boston College Alum
and as a dad of a kid who just went
through the recruiting process and
Boston College is one of the kind of the
final schools that he was deciding
between it's really surprising but at
the same time having just been through
that recruiting process as a dad it's a
lot man like college football I call it
professional college football right now
it it never ends so whether you're
talking nil transfer portal recruiting
recruiting your own kids not to leave uh
some schools are more committed to
spending money um to go get guys to keep
guys uh some schools are more committed
to you know honestly this next whatever
the future of professional college
football looks like versus the
amateurism I think it's tough I I I was
surprised I think you'll see more
coaches uh kick and Claw and scratch to
get their way back into the NFL could
you see Bill bich entertaining the idea
of coing Harvard
football yeah yeah I've never heard
anyone say that but yeah I I really
actually thought that the most
surprising thing he would probably try
to do is go Coach men's lacrosse
somewhere like I think he would love
that challenge as long as it lines up
with his summers at Nantucket sure uh
the Harvard thing is really interesting
though because as you may or may not
know there are a lot of restrictions uh
there's basically uh you don't have the
guys in the summer the way the division
one programs do uh that the amount of
hours you have so you could like coach
football and in theory still have a life
outside of it so pretty good idea Dan I
I like I like where your head's at well
Tim Murphy what he just retired after 30
years bills in the neighborhood um maybe
he would like that you're not dealing
with transfer portal or nil as much as
you would someplace else and it would
allow him to coach in a conference that
he would have great respect for so I
know pretty good you should be his agent
I know there's some coaches on staff
there that have been there a long time
that um that understand how to work with
admissions there and so that's a whole
another that's a whole another Beast
that you have to deal with at some
schools but I was wondering I don't know
if Bill bich will coach in the NFL game
again and the reason why I say this is
one more year he's going to be
73 who's turning over their organization
to somebody who how how long's he going
to be there um someone who wants to win
well I like I thought Philadelphia was
going to go after him and replace nick
serani uh at Atlanta they wanted him
until the front office probably said
well wait a minute he's going to take
our jobs or our jobs are in Jeopardy and
then they didn't want him Washington at
the last you know 11th Hour reaches out
to him without an interview but they
reach out to him so I don't I don't know
if I see a franchise going yep let's
bring in
bill I think you need to look at the
decision maker like if it's the GM if
the GM is kind of the decision maker
like of course they're not going to say
oh yeah hey come and be my boss please
you know but if it's an owner who's like
hey I've had enough I just want to pay a
large sum of money and I want you to
just do it go bring me a great football
team I will go do the business stuff
like just do it and if if if you kind of
find one of those types of owners and
Coach belich sees a situation where the
quarterback is already a settled thing I
I I say yes I say yes yeah I'm just I
I'm just I was curious about it because
the more I thought about it the more I'm
thinking uh if it didn't work this time
Vel didn't get a
job that's tough you know it's it's
musical chairs right and there's there's
like a there's a point of emphasis right
now for like the Young hip cool
analytics streamlining you know all the
kind of stuff the League's getting a lot
younger you see Pete Carol get pushed
out you see you know Bill bich get
pushed out like that's the trend this
year I don't know like if Kyle Shanahan
wins the Super Bowl then sure that
trend's probably going to continue like
the new age stuff but if Andy Reid wins
the Super Bowl then it might be a trend
it's a very copycat League then the
trend might be like you know what we
don't need to re invent the wheel
football a great leader a great football
coach is a great football coach let's
copy that model he's Matt hbec former
NFL quarterback former NFL Analyst at
the mothership if I told you this would
be the Super Bowl matchup back in August
you would have said what I say oh that's
a boring pick that's not a hot take I
agree with you but we're looking for a
hot take and that's I think what
everybody does at the beginning of the
year they want to be the person that
bets on the underdog horse or whatever
but no for sure like these two teams
these are you know probably the the the
best team in the NFC last year who you
know outside of Brock P's injury uh
would had a great chance to be in the
Super Bowl and and this year I mean Andy
Reid momes Travis Kelce um of course
safe bet safe bet pick out the weakness
of both of these
teams the weakness I think of the I I
shouldn't say the weakness I think the
Kryptonite like if you want to beat the
Chiefs there's one thing you have to do
like there's you can't beat them unless
you do this unless you eliminate Travis
Kelce you need to take him out of the
you need to find other ways to lose the
game find other ways to lose he needs to
be the guy and I just tell you like
every time I played against the Chiefs
in my career or a team like the Chiefs
this is how it would go down you'd have
a scout team player probably one of your
better wide receivers play tight end all
week in practice wear a jersey with the
number eight and seven and sometimes it
was two different guys and it was like
we don't care what happens 87's not
touching the ball in practice for two
weeks now it'll be that way or it should
be that way and that's the whole
emphasis and then you go watch like a
game like the Buffalo Bills game and
they're just like dropping coverage and
they're just letting Kelsey Run free
like that's not it like Jacksonville
learned the hard way last year the teams
who've done a good job against Kansas
City they eliminate they make them win
another way some other way so that's I
think that's the biggest thing and then
for San Fran I think Health like they've
got some star players they just got to
be healthy Brock P's got to be healthy
Debo KD uh they have the weapons but uh
to me Kelsey is like if you want to pick
one thing it's got to be
Travis was Tom Brady a game
manager he was a game what's the right
word he was a game Commander he was a
game controller okay so we got to change
the the the word manager that's that's
the problem manager like manager reminds
me of like a grocery store clerk from
like a kind of like a mediocre movie
that I watched or something like uh I
need a manager on a aisle four like no I
I I want I want someone in charge I want
a I want a commander a controller
someone who dictates what's going to
happen in the game okay Tom Brady had
the ability to win a game going over the
top to Randy Moss he had the ability to
win the game by death by a thousand
paper cuts to James White and he
intimidated defensive coordinators
defensive coordinators like pton Manning
was this way too defensive coordinators
would be afraid to do certain things
blitzes or whatever could be like oh no
he's gonna he's gonna see it he's gonna
Dink and dunk like whatever it is so I I
think yeah change the word so Brock pie
is he a game manager he's a baller I
don't care listen honestly like just
even this morning I went back and
rewatched uh I went back and rewatched
all of his completions from the last two
playoff games dude is a freaking Beast
I'm sorry I know he doesn't look like a
beast I know like if he had a we at the
combine you strip down to your underwear
or whatever you're not going to be like
whoa look how tall he is look how strong
look how CH like probably not he's like
uh he's like one of the best I don't
know Short Stops I've ever seen he
catches it he's smooth balls on point
runnner ball accurate on time but he
does I don't care what anybody says and
I don't even know if people say this but
he has wow throws he absolutely has wow
throws let rewind that let me see that
wow but I think the thing that he and
Patrick Mahomes both don't get enough
credit for people wna I don't know I
don't think people realize what great
Runners these quarterbacks are and
they're not like they're not running
quarterbacks but when their team
absolutely needs it they will run for a
first down and absolutely break the back
of a defense ironically we already know
that about momes but like even in this
playoff run uh uh P's done it more than
momes and we know how good Mahomes is so
um no that I I think Mo Moxy
Swagger um Instinct instinctual on time
Rhythm accuracy all all the things
that's why these are the two teams
playing for it all because they're
quarterbacks are that way if momes wins
another Super Bowl
MVP does that do anything status wise
pecking order anything
historically sure of course um you know
to me just what they've already done you
know everyone said oh no one will ever
be as good as Joe Montana then all of a
sudden Tom Brady came along then
everyone said oh no one will ever do
what Tom Brady did and I I agree but
then here's momes like in the prime of
his career doing it like this dude I I
say this sometimes to people people are
like oh can you believe how long uh Tom
Brady played it's not even how long he
played it's how many games he played in
that stretch like this dude played 20
something he played over a a full season
of playoff games so like when a other
NFL quarterbacks who throw for a ton of
yards they're over in the Bahamas
playing golf and the during the playoffs
Tom Brady is still playing football
that's what momes has done I mean this
dude's like he never gets a break he's
got a short off season every season so
that he's ridiculous he's so good uh
Andy Reid's so good um you know who's
underrated though I gotta got to tell
you is uh Steve spagnolo the defensive
coordinator for the Chiefs and and and I
don't know like I played against him
when he was with the the St Louis Rams I
played against someone who was with the
New York Giants with those great Michael
straan OC um manora Antonio Pierce
defenses um to me he is like when I
think of spags I think of like dick laau
you know and I because I don't know what
people think of spags I think it's
almost like an afterthought because how
good the offense is but no this this
dude deserves the same amount of respect
as a defensive coordinator as you'd give
someone like dick leau which is kind of
like the highest compliment I can think
of yeah and I I've asked Our Guest the
last couple of days if you're San
Francisco are you more concerned about
Kansas City C's defense or Patrick
Mahomes Kansas City's defense is really
good here's the thing you need to be
concerned about Travis Kelce like that
needs to be priority number one he's the
guy where's Waldo find him every play
like that's our whole thing kelse is one
then momes too or the
defense defense is really good I think
this is the great thing about s Fran why
they're so good is they don't care who
you are on defense they don't care
they're going to do them it's like they
got this like John Wood mindset you know
what we're going to do a shift a lot of
teams shift and a lot of teams motion
watch the 49ers they'll do a shift and a
motion so much shift Motion Set Hut
defense has to think we're not thinking
we're on offense we know it's just a
shift motion we do this all time shift
motion set hut shift motion set hut the
defense is over like I got him you got
him you got Debo CAC KD like what so I
think that's the beauty of it I think
the thing that you you that's different
about Kansas City right now is the Run
game Isaiah p
like again another thing we don't talk
about but um czecho is the real deal I
mean he runs angry he runs well they're
committed to it more than I think they
have been and that you know that's a way
to close out a game I don't know it's
super fun I I love saman Fran there's so
much to like about San Fran I love
Kansas City they're an all-time team
like you know when did you grow up
watching football when when when Kansas
City and Mahomes were doing their thing
it's like a it's how you define an era
kind of so super super fun should be an
awesome game yeah I just you know
Mahomes has got into the Brady
Stratosphere I don't bet against him I
just if he's out there I can't bet
against him if I was coaching if I was
coaching if I was coaching Patrick I
would say Patrick the only thing that
can beat you is you like don't get bored
you know he won the super he won his
last Super Bowl um I made this analogy
last year with a three-wood the whole
year you know he didn't have he didn't
have Tyreek and he was like you know
what I'm putting the driver away I'm
gonna use my three-wood when I'm go I
need to more I'm going to spread it
around I'm going to use everybody and
that's what he did he used everybody he
let the offense work for him and I don't
know it's it's it's special but uh I
think he's his he's the only thing that
could stop him in a weird way great to
talk to you thanks for joining us Matt
always always a pleasure did your son
get nil did did UCLA offer up anything
there when they I think they know how
much money I made in my career so we
never got out at any nil you don't need
nil you know you told your son you're
not getting nil money from UCLA he's
been on nil since he was born who are we
kidding come on come on thank you Matt
all right Matt Hassel back former NFL
quarterback